It's Like a Jungle Sometimes it makes me
wonder how I keep from [__] going
under you understand me so freezing like
a [__] penguin listen
you're doing way better than [__] me
but that's not always the case the
summer I was nine I worked for a [__]
flower shop let me tell you something it
was like a filet mignon stuffed with
shrimp his name was Peter Pinto he used
to play with his teeth people get pissed
at me all the times [__] you
[__] you I thought this was important
that's it [__] suckers
it's brought to you by on it go to
audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Wednesday the 23rd of
March the joint is brought to you by
freeze pipe
spring is here the bees are buzzing the
flowers are blooming and if you want to
smoke that flour you'll need the best
[__] pipe around you get a nice cold
hit every time
freeze pipe I love this thing the pipe
comes with a detachable chamber that you
freeze beforehand when you're ready to
[__] see the devil that hot smoke
passes through the Frozen part cooling
it down as you inhale your smoke will be
so [__] cold you think your Frosty
the [__] snowman let me tell you
something I love my freeze pipe the
bubbler is the only thing I use it's
small it's personal and it blows
tremendous [__] smokes and guess what
my throat's not sore the next day it's
like living in Colorado it's non-toxic
freezes faster than water and stays
Frozen for [__] ever freeze pipe
cools the smoke down by hundreds of
degrees in other words your throat won't
hurt your throat won't burn it is
tremendous so what I'm doing for the
joint listeners go to the freeze
pipe.com
thefreeze pipe.com and pressing code
Joey j-o-e-y I'm Gonna Save You 10 on
your first order I'm showing you the
bong I got the [__] Bubba the pipe is
tremendous listen start with the [__]
bubbler see the devil and then get back
to me you'll be begging me to get you a
discount on the bong that's thefreeze
pipe.com
pressing code Joey to save 10 I'll tell
you what go for a [__] if you can
smoke from it freeze pipe makes it again
call Joey to get you 10 off on your
order the joint is also brought to you
by c b d lion listen when it comes to
CBD you could be confused till the cows
come home is all all these companies all
these people telling you what they can
and can't do I'm here to tell you what
CB lion does and that supplies you with
100 CBD they've got these patches these
little [__] patches that you put on
your shoulder your knee your thigh
tremendous their CBD infused they have
cream they have the patches they have
the the bad salts they have capsules if
you want to smoke from a vapor pen you
can if you want the original hemp with
the CBD that's what CBD lion does so do
me a favor go to cbdlion.com right now
read the third party lab results and see
how it can help you once you find that
product whether it be a tincture a
kinesiology tape a gummy with melatonin
you order it in your press code Joey or
joint and get 20 sent off your [__]
order you Savages enough with the
[__] CBD at a gas station is not
going to work for you at the lion it'll
work for you so go to CBD lion pressing
code Joey and get 20 off with CBD Lion
now if you don't mind let's get this
[__] party started
doors money
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here it's Wednesday who the
[__] knows the 23rd of the month who the
[__] gives this [__] every day's a
[__] struggle It's Like a Jungle
Sometimes it makes me wonder how I keep
from [__] going under you understand
me so
it's a beautiful day to be alive uh
softball's back I was at that field
[__] Monday night freezing like a
[__] penguin even Jimmy Florentine
tells me all the time that feels it's
haunted there's something wrong with
that field there could be a hundred
[__] degrees and if you go to that
particular field you [__] freeze once
the Sun goes behind the trees listen I
had a [__]
what's those uh what's the thing that
everybody Wears Like long t-shirts
whatever the [__] Ultra or whatever had
one of those on
add a hooded sweatshirt on the thickest
one I have and my longest yard [__]
blanket on
and I was still freezing my wife's like
why are you bringing a blanket I go
watch me [__] this is Jersey I
don't trust nothing I take a jacket
everywhere now I get [__] cold I I
don't understand what happens when you
get old but let me tell you something I
had the blanket the hooded sweatshirt
and the hooded sweatshirt tied that's a
big difference right there you can have
a hooded sweatshirt on but if you got
that [__] tied you know it's
called that cause the wind is going in
your ears and whatnot
so uh we're back to that we got games
practices
but who gives a [__] I'm out there
getting vitamin D watching [__] girls
run and steal home and who gives a [__]
you know I've been getting a lot I get a
lot of [__] emails you know lots of
emails
and a lot of questions for some reason
you know that's how I know
that
you know younger people right now are
just uh lost but then again when I was
21 listen I was lost while I was [__]
44 years old
so when you if you're making comparisons
there you have it you're doing a lot
you're doing way better than [__] me
you know
people always ask me if you had to do it
again what would you do what wouldn't
you do what do you think was the most
important thing you did
and you know I got I had to think about
it for a while like I was getting so
many of these that I was like
it's time to really [__] think you
know you give somebody like a [__]
answer like you know you gotta do what
you love or whatever but that's not
always the case sometimes you do [__]
and you sometimes you do something when
you're 16. right like when I was
the summer I was nine I worked for a
[__] uh flower shop my stepdad was
Partners on a flower shop that summer
and the guy that owned the flower shop
with him also had a butcher shop so they
gave me a [__] job they gave me like
a dual job in the mornings I would work
the flower shop that's where I could
steal and in the afternoons I worked a
butcher shop which was down the block
from the [__] uh whatever shop when I
mean steel like somebody comes in for
four flowers you charge them eight bucks
I would charge them like six and keep
two you know when you're nine two
dollars a lot of [__] money you know
and trust me at that time like I told
you guys I learned how to steal in New
Jersey at that time it was me and the
fly a fly a floral assistant and he's
the one that told me because I do this
all day
so in New Jersey everybody takes a
little piece off the [__] top you
know so I was you know I was doing it
like three times that was petrified
because I'm scared my stepfather would
catch me then he'd say something to my
mother and then he'd tell my mother you
see we gotta [__] tighten his realm
or his Reign so
I would go on a flower shop dog you know
to work at a flower shop I don't know if
you guys know this you got to get it
before in the [__] morning
you got to go into the city
pick up [__] flowers gladiolos roses
and then you gotta bring the Roses back
and [__] be stem them do you have any
idea what that just sit there with
gloves
you leave there you're like a [__]
porcupine like a pin cushion
and then in the afternoons I have to go
to the butcher shop and clean up throw
away the old meat I would try to [__]
use a knife but they wouldn't let me
because if I caught myself I would bleed
and they didn't want me to [__] pass
out on the butcher shop so I would go
into the freeze I remember so [__]
hot then that I would [__] do
something outside for 10 minutes and
then run in and I would just sit in the
[__] meat for refrigerator for hours
for hours I would go how long could I
sit in here today I would hide in there
for an hour hour and a half smelling
that stinky [__] meat I didn't smoke
dope but I was just a [__] kid you
know
but uh and that did that come back to
help me later on you know what it helped
me with conversations about roses people
didn't know and help me with
Arrangements like I love floral
arrangements and uh I love all that type
of [__] so yeah it came back but if I
have to if I had to think about what
helped me the most in my career that I
thought would never help I gotta go back
to [__] sales sales listen selling
yourself is the oldest [__] career in
the book yeah prostitution is but I
think it got there she walks up to the
guy and says hey do you want to take a
walk on the [__] Wild Side you know
what I'm saying yeah a woman ever come
to you in proposition you and you're
like [__] no maybe she's ugly maybe
she's chubby maybe you just didn't like
the way she [__] she said it to you
well she's not a skilled salesman you
know a skilled sales woman would have
came one time I bumped into a hooker and
[__] uh Hell's Kitchen I was working
on 57th and 12th selling [__] Jeeps
down there and I used to take the port
authority and I used to get the [__] in
the city at 8 15. and I'll never forget
like I had never seen this before in my
life I know people go out at night and
get their dick sucked you get a hooker
you find they're on the corner maybe at
the library you know maybe at your
favorite 7-Eleven I understand that but
for a hooker to come up to me at eight
in the morning
when I got orange juice in my hand a
[__] bran muffin and they're like hey
you want to have a date and you're like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it's [__]
eight in the morning what are you
thinking I just woke up I don't even
have a bump in me yet and the chick's
like dog this chick hounded me she got
together with me like on 48th Street and
this [__] followed me to like 57th
Street and I gotta be honest with you
I you know how I feel about hookers and
at that point in my life I was uh
30 it was 1993 so I was 30 years old I
was a wild man and at that point in my
life I had no money this chick was so
far like I didn't have
the amount of money that she needed you
follow me I don't know what she wanted
for a [__] but I didn't have the
money that's how broke I was I was I was
doing comedy I was selling cars I was
driving a limo I was just trying to pay
child support and my addiction and all
this [__] and this [__] is working me
for a piece of ass let me tell you
something the piece of ass she described
to me was like a filet mignon stuffed
with shrimp with [__] I mean she
described the piece of [__] to me that
I could not even
I I I I was like what I couldn't even
wait the [__] even though I hate
prostitutes and I hate sticking my dick
in dirty [__] things like that she
had me convinced that if I didn't eat
her [__] and all this [__] I was gonna
miss out for the rest of my life I
remember the whole day I walked around
like what the [__] did I do I should
have borrowed 20 bucks or something like
that no that chick was a Salesman sure
enough she should bring me home and her
[__] smells like a [__] tire store
and flat ass and she got cesarean scars
and [__] junky [__] veins and [__]
I I know this
but the way she sold me that piece of
[__] it was like the last piece of
[__] on Earth
that the rest of the day I'm like and I
was selling cars on 57th as well and I'm
like that [__] was a Salesman she made
me rethink everything about salesmanship
everything how to describe and that
description was why you [__]
like well Joey's a good Storyteller well
because you describe you learn to
describe
different things the smell of the room
when you walk in a sock the way it was
raining it was just a mess description
is everything
so I knew nothing about sales
when I was about 20 21 Gregory Krikorian
they got it on Gregory's seven day
weekend pulled me aside one day he's
like hey man
I think you'd be a good [__] car
sales I'm like what the [__] are you
talking about
he's like dog just listen to what I'm
telling you I got an eye for that [__]
I'm the top salesman in the country this
guy was a [__] wild man
and I'm like are you and I'd see him
with his white shirts and his Ties on I
don't know if he got one day when I was
like a sophomore he came out we were
outside in the [__] snow by Nick's
Pizza on 76th and Kennedy Boulevard and
Corky's is right next to it I don't know
if I go one one morning I was over there
just hanging out selling mescaline and I
see cookie come out with his sales shirt
a tie and blood on his shirt from a fist
fight he got in the night before and
he's telling me how he's gonna go to
work and I'm like what the [__] you got
blood on your shirt anyway this guy
could sell [__] anything
so for a year this guy tormented me Joey
when are you going to get on the line
and sell
enjoy when are you going to get online
I have no [__] idea I was on coke and
[__] I didn't know and finally
like in early 85 I called him up one day
and I go corks I'm gonna take you
your uh
he worked at Manhattan I went over there
a couple times it was [__] beautiful
it was the place you want to work that
action everybody had a shirt and a tie
on and was like [__] I want to work he's
like nah he don't start here I'm gonna
start you on Route 46 in Jersey selling
used cars and I'm like oh I don't want
to do that but he said listen
if you take this job you're helping me
out and I'll give you a couple [__]
dollars a week so you know me dog at
that age I was a [__] bum I didn't
really want to sell he gave me some book
on selling I looked at it and I'm like
[__] this you don't need to read a book
on selling that I didn't sell [__] I
must have been there for three months I
think I sold a half a car the guy liked
me I made him laugh or some [__]
so I was like I'm not gonna do this ever
again this is a stupid idea cookie
didn't know what he was talking about
I end up in Colorado you know I'm
washing cars I'm a [__] detailer I
tried everything I'm drying cars at the
puddle so I get this job at Boulder auto
body as a [__] shagger
and you know after a while you have to
deliver cars to different dealerships
and [__] like that was just a body shop
Shack shagger but for some reason
they're like Joey you got to help us
move the cars back and forth to the
dealers
and there was this one deal his name was
Peter Pinto he used to play with his
teeth you know those guys in that false
teeth and they play with them with their
tongue and you hear them [__]
chomping and this guy was young too I
don't know he was like a hockey player
or something he told me he was from
Florida via New Jersey or something
[__] good dude he was a creepy
looking [__] and he was a creepy
dude he you know I'm sure he had a
couple rapes on his resume and [__] you
know I'm one of those type of people
but he took a liking to me I would
always bring cars to him and throw the
keys up you know and and say What's
Happening Here you [__] and
he's like this kid's crazy and one day I
was outside
and they came up to me he's like can I
have a worry I'm like [__] this guy's
gonna [__] rat me out about stinking
like weed or being hung over and he's
like hey man
I'll never forget how he described this
to me he goes hey man you got the gift
of God
I'm like what what are you talking about
the gift of what he goes you have to
gift the gap
that means that you could [__] sell
whatever the [__] you want I'm like what
are you talking about I got no sales
experience I've only sold cocaine he
started laughing he goes if you can sell
Coke you could sell cars I go listen I
tried it once before I was horrible at
it it wasn't nice like come back I'm
like [__] you every time I see him when
are you gonna come sell when are you
gonna come sell one of them comes out
then one day he talked money that's the
key about sales he goes you know how
much these guys making here and I go
what he goes about four to seven
thousand some guys make eight to ten
thousand a month he goes I guarantee you
come to work with me within the first
month you'll be making six thousand a
month
I got you full of [__]
and he goes well put me to the test I'll
bet you that you will make six thousand
dollars your first month and I'm like
so he goes I'll tell you what I'll do
coming on a Saturday because I told him
I said listen what if I came in one day
and tried it for one day and I could
give you my answer I can't lose my other
job you know I was a dog I was making
280 a week at the other job 200 a week I
was getting less than minimum [__]
wage but that's the job you got to take
to be a trainee at that place
and I couldn't live off it I was [__]
dying I was eating Ramen and [__] I
couldn't snore Coke I couldn't have it
I'm about to go back and steal I'm not
gonna have it so what was going to save
me from [__] stealing again six
thousand dollars a month
so one Saturday I [__] put together a
shoots a shirt some great pants I had
some black shoes and like a a sports
jacket I borrowed from my neighbor and
when I got there some dude uh Carlos
Valverde God Rest his soul I talked to
his daughter online
Shia here
gave me a time he goes I got an extra
time my [__] desk and it was a
Saturday it was April it was [__]
tremendous the weather was a beautiful
[__] day
and I went out there on my first [__]
day and sold three cars
I made like 600 bucks and I made like a
hundred bonuses cash because they have
that t uh
[__] fist CIF so you get those bonuses
it means cash and fist
dog I'll never forget I was like Ralph
Kramden when Ralph Cramton found the
money on the [__] on the bus in in
Brooklyn he [__] brought it home they
told him bring it back and come back in
30 days if nobody claims it it's [__]
yours so he went back in 30 days he
brings the suitcase home he opens it up
and it's filled with 100 [__] bills
his wife said to him what are you gonna
do she goes first thing I'm gonna do is
this he goes over picks up the phone and
he goes he calls his boss at work and he
goes I quit and [__] you you know like
and he hangs up on him she goes he goes
what are you going to do I go I'm going
to [__] call the detail shop watch
this I call him up and they're like hey
we'll see you Monday at seven I go no
you won't
no you won't I am not working at Boulder
Auto Body no more I am now I built
crotch [__] Subaru I don't know what
to think he was a good guy too I called
him back and I made up and they
understood because I knew you were going
to leave you're too [__] wild to work
in be a detailer
and I went over there and the one thing
I enjoyed about him the difference
between him and [__] Corky was that
there was a training period
there was a two-week training period I
didn't really listen I could sell [__]
but I just didn't know I was a Salesman
I had no [__] idea I was shy to go up
to somebody and go hey buy this [__]
car but after watching those Savages and
how they did it they would just hang out
outside but they were all velvet hammers
what does that mean that when one of
those [__] in the head you're
going down and you're not even going to
feel it that's what a velvet hammer
[__] is
I never forget the guy that took me
under his wing over there his name was
Jim wheeler he was the used car manager
he was a bad ass [__] out of
Detroit
so they said listen for the first week
you're just going to Shadow him you're
just gonna [__] bring go out there
show customers a car ask them if they
want to buy don't say a [__] word
bring them in to Jim wheeler and he'll
close them at first I didn't like it
because the motherfucker's taking half
my deal I'm the one that's out there
hustling these [__]
and he's like uh watch we'll do it
you'll still make money
and I would go out there
and I would do it to the T how they
taught me the meet and greet you know
ask them questions always talk to the
[__] wife first because ninety
percent of a household is run by a wife
yeah the man is the king of the castle
but the wife makes the [__] buying
decisions you know you learn all these
little tricks you know uh
just agreed them
just to warm them up loosen them up a
little bit show them the cars you know
but at the same time like I would do it
like the first couple [__] weeks I
worked there I wouldn't want nothing to
happen and I was such a [__] because I
would never ask for the sale
I would always after that that more ride
I'd come back you like the car yeah all
right let's go inside I wouldn't and
then Jim would come up and [__] start
drilling how you guys doing yeah do you
like Joey did he show you the car yeah
okay so what do you guys want to do and
they're like I don't know we'll look
around no and we were getting their ass
nah why don't we sit down and go through
numbers and I swear to God every time he
would say that [__] to him I would just
go
how [__] embarrassing like you can't
ask only if they want to buy I was such
a [__] [__] and I would sit that I
was desperate I would sit there across
from him and like if he said something
wrong I would I would stick up for the
people and he'd pull me aside and go
don't you ever [__] do that again
there's a science to this I'm like what
do you mean there's a science to this I
thought you just talk to people no no no
there's a science to this
you gotta work them I sold Coke all
those years and even with Coke I had a
science I was like oh this guy's on to
something
because even with Coke in the [__]
80s when everybody was selling forty
five dollar [__] half grams of 50
half grams they gave you powder with a
little glass in it so yeah let's say the
guy bought an eight ball of Solitaire he
threw a gram cut on it he got four and a
half back you're still gonna get great
[__] cocaine you're gonna have a
little cut in it I went a little better
when I sold Coke I gave you a rock
I gave you a little rock and then I took
like a gram of let's say I got an eight
ball and the guy gave me two and a half
gram of rock I would take that one gram
and I'd throw a half gram on that
[__] and maybe throw another
gram of powder on that and I'd break it
up
and I give you a rock with a little bit
of powder like you like Joey that's
that's a pretty good [__] match
because I wanted you to always get a
great deal
I even made him a little heavy I would
let's say a half gram is 0.5 I would
make them point six so yeah I always
wanted to give you a [__] fair deal
that's the one thing about me I'm not in
business to [__] beat you if you want
me to beat you I'll beat you I'll put
you in a trunk of a car and [__] sell
your cocaine I've done it before I'll do
it again that's not it you know so all
these things really [__] help me
and then I got involved in everything
sales
like I bought every book on sales and
[__] read them I did
you know I did everything when I'm a
sales like I'm dying to go sell again
something I just don't have the time I
don't have 60 hours a week
to go [__] battle cars but eventually
I'll tell you if they don't give me
[__] insurance this year when the
Screen Actors Guild and the [__] uh
the guy who died
held a lawsuit on the Screen Actors
Guild but he [__] died but it's a
federal lawsuit and the judge said no
even if he's dead we're still going to
[__] run this lawsuit so hopefully
after this lawsuit comes in all of us
get our insurance back maybe a little
Buck a lot but besides that who gives a
[__] we're talking about [__] sales
here it's the most important thing so
I'm [__] uh at Subaru and after about
three weeks
I was watching this guy his name was
Rick Visser
while all the other guys were smoking
dope and jumping up and down
and shooting heroin and robbing banks at
lunchtime Carlos Valverde I mean this
dealership was Buckwild
they had two Indian brothers that were
[__] gigantic like the two dudes from
The Outlaw Josie Wales
dog and then they went over to the
Suzuki store because Subaru had a Crouch
at a Suzuki store and they were driving
a custom remember when the I don't know
if you guys remember the Suzuki Jeeps
they used to tip over real easy well
these [__] two Indians were 400
pounds apiece they hit a curb one day
and bouldered a [__] Jeep flipped
over tremendous anyway who gives a [__]
about Suzuki Jeeps so after about three
weeks
I really started [__] like
how much can you make in people like six
thousand you know [__] even more than
at the time Subaru had a tremendous deal
going
I think they paid you 30 percent
if you it took seven cars to make your
bonus
if you hit seven cars you got a free car
but if you hit eight cars they'd give
you a 500 bonus are you [__] kidding
me so you have all these bonuses
along the way now you're saying to me
joy why would somebody want to sell
okay I'm gonna tell you why somebody
would want to sell you ever go for a job
they're giving you right now if you get
a job today in Jersey you're getting 16
an hour
16.50 targets paying 25 [__] dollars
that's a target's paying right now
so if I was half of you [__]
I'd be over in Target in the fish
section right now [__] battery
section trying to earn some cash 25 is
not bad for [__] Target but my point
is to ever get a [__] job you're not
making enough money and you look at it
you're like
dog I'm making 300 a week that's 1200 a
month my rent is six how am I going to
break even well
some people don't mind living in a space
where they have a ceiling on their
income
you make 600 a week that's 2400 a
[__] a month
that's thirty thousand dollars a [__]
year that's what you're gonna get
some people have to sit down look at
that and go
that's the number I could live by
I don't want to sell Coke I don't want
to go to prison I don't want to sell
weed I don't want to go to prison
how else can I make that money I tell
you how with a [__] sales job
because you have no ceiling on your
income
you could have really really good months
or you could have a a really good month
and still do a lot better than you're
doing at that job if you have a bad
month then you get zilch there's no
[__] safety net there's no nothing if
you're in the car business
they'll give you a bottom line salad if
you can live off that they'll give you
three four hundred a week that's 1600 a
[__] month but let me ask you a
question if I'm giving you the potential
to make ten thousand a week why would
you settle for the 1600 a [__] month
when you can make ten thousand dollars a
month just talking to people that's all
it is and when I realize that I'm like
whoa I gotta work on this so I read
everything I could
I read all the literature on Subaru I
learned
the literature because in Boulder
they're Engineers it's a smarter caliber
of person that's asking you questions
you just can't jump and jive with them
a lot of times I would say I don't know
when you're selling you want to appear
to be the dumbest man on the earth if
you really want to be a good salesman
you got to be a [__] dummy or act
like one
and you know just like you don't know
anything
do you know what this car costs I have
no idea we could check the book but
what's the price taker on that the price
stickers 18 9 or 18.9 that's a that's a
price of the past on a [__] sticker
have you looked at stickers lately
they're [__] out there so you look at
a car what's the stick around at 32 like
right now today there's a shortage of
cars you're paying MSRP
that's it manufactured suggested retail
price you're paying MSRP they might
throw an addendum on that [__] car if
you people don't know the car business
an addendum it's what's next to the MSRP
and that's what tells you what they're
going to charge you extra for that's
[__] it's like muffin Duff wax uh
high-end radio whatever that's all
[__] you disqualify that a good
salesman starts by that number some
people don't even start there okay I'll
start at MSRP I always started from
[__] addendum you know I worked at
Bill Crouch for about a year and I
really
got interrupted with me going to prison
as a matter of fact now I'm lying to you
guys
I went to prison the second time I
worked at Bill Crouch I worked at Bill
Crouch for about eight to nine months
I learned a lot of good [__] you know I
learned uh
how to sell in volume
I went from being a liner
being a liner is you greet the people
you show them a car you put them in the
car you test drive and then you bring
them back and you hand them to a closer
I became at that Subaru spot in eight
months I became from being a
a liner
I became a closer I started learning how
to close my own deals you know most
dealerships have two teams The A Team
and the B team and that's how you
excuse me that's how you make your
schedule so Monday the 18 comes in from
nine to five the B Team comes in from
three to nine so you always have an
overlap for salesmen and they call each
other [__] and there's an argument and
a whole [__] deal now so that's how
you determine there's no big deal on
that so then Tuesday B would come in
first and then so on and so forth
Wednesday B would be in all day a would
have the day off Thursday a would have
the d off uh B would be in all day you
follow him saying to you so that was the
schedule I never took a day off
I didn't believe in days off salesmen
don't take days off we work seven days a
week if the dealership is closed on
Sunday then I'm definitely not taking a
day off usually you go into the daily
shipling your day off just to look
around to see what's going on maybe you
bump into something after an hour or two
three hours you don't bump into
something somebody tells you they got a
joint to smoke [__] and sell out V I'm
out of here take two steps to the rear
and get out of here so
my first eight months I rarely took a
day off
I [__] worked every day and I studied
out of the eight months I worked at I
had seven phenomenal months and one
horrific month my fourth month
why Joey because when you get into sales
when you first start the first 90 days
you're a [__] [__] look I'm 60 years
old I'm still a [__] [__] but you're
a [__] [__]
as a matter of sales the first month you
pick up a couple good sales
the second month you do better the third
month you do fantastic but guess what
happens
now you become a Salesman you forgot to
be stupid you got too smart
and the fourth month you'll have a slump
you can't [__] I mean it's it's a
slump
that old [__] devastate yeah
everybody you talked I don't want to buy
I came in looking for a tricycle you
know everybody and you're like what the
[__] you start to lose it
and that's what I did and then Jim
wheeler reeled me back and he goes you
got to go back to basics
you know and
while I was there I also noticed that
salesmanship
was not just about selling a car
there's a lot more of that you know
there's people that actually are
shoppers
I I'm a Salesman my job is to take a
shopper and create a flip them into a
buyer that's what a Salesman does okay a
Salesman job is to take a shopper and
flip them into a buyer to buy a car
today but sometimes that's not gonna
[__] happen
people really want time to think about
it they're intelligent people remember
all these people in Boulder will [__]
nobody finances in Boulder
everybody buys cash and nobody has bad
credit
when you come to a store any other store
outside of Boulder you come into my
store you look a little fishy I make you
do a five-line credit app before we even
show you a call I'm not going to waste
three hours to find out you never paid
your water bill in 2019 during the
pandemic I got to work there for six
hours to find out then [__] you if you
look a little [__] cheesy let's go
inside let's do a credit let me see what
car I can put you in and then it comes
back in and pay electric bill you just
kick them on the street look down there
they got cars you can look at all day go
to the mall you can look at cars all day
go to them all they got every [__]
car you want at the mall right or wrong
you got a Freehold Mall right down there
just drive around they got SUVs you can
see any car and that's what I would tell
people you know I hit a buy okay then go
to the mall walk around why are you
wasting my time for you can look at
every [__] car in the world at the
mall that's when you get smart when you
get smart and you're a Salesman you're
done there's [__] rules to the game
and especially to become a closer
there's rules to the game you give
somebody an offer it's going to blow
them out of their [__] pants don't
say a word
because the first one who speaks loses
let them [__] talk there's all these
little things that you learned stay
stupid I don't know nothing what do you
think till this day I say I don't know
nothing
because that's something I learned
selling [__] cars why I learned it in
Jersey on the streets as a kid but as I
got older it got cemented in my [__]
mind with the car business you don't
know nothing how much for the car I
don't know what do you mean you don't
know you were still I don't know I'm
like how much tire pressure is in the I
don't know I'll check with the service
department what's the speakers in there
how many speakers I don't know I'll
check once you start becoming an
authority now you're giving them a
[__] reason to chit chat I don't know
I don't know I don't know do you want to
buy the car well I don't know and you
just keep going back to that [__]
thing
you know and I was always a good
salesman so when I left Bill crowd super
I went over to Chrysler
and that dude's name was Artie Presley
that [__] was a badass Jew
that guy took me and re-fucking trained
me and all the things I learned in the
car business all those [__] years
came back and helped me with [__]
comedy later on
because no matter what job you end up
with it's always going to come to the
same thing selling yourself how are you
going to get that job when you walk into
interview
you know I read rolling stone every week
that no no why are you here
because I really want that [__] job
because I want three [__] kids and I
you know I got three [__] kids I
gotta pay bills I got a mortgage those
are the [__] you want to go
after you know but at the same [__]
time
I went over the uh already Pressler was
a genius
he was a genius
he wanted you to slow the [__]
down again
that's slowing a person down you learn
that with comedy too slow him down
stop them set them down
explain to them how they're going to buy
a car from you and you're going to
change their [__] life I was like wow
this [__] knows about
dealing the [__] that they didn't teach
me at Bill Crouch this guy [__]
just blew my mind with
so at Bill crowd she just brought him in
and if they wanted to buy something you
gave them a credit app you gave them the
paperwork you told me you're gonna go
look for a car for them and uh they did
they paid their own credit app and [__]
meanwhile you're trying to figure out
how to rob these people not with Artie
Pressler with our Pressler
[__] sit down and he wanted you to
take a five line credit out from maybe
everybody and you fill it in
and the reason why is because while
people are telling you they're telling
you their most intimate situation what's
your name you come in you say I'm Mike
okay hi Mike but once I set you down
what's your name Michael Anthony Klein
you're telling me your middle name I
just [__] met you you know people 20
years you never tell them you're [__]
middle name I already know your middle
name what's your address they give you
address which is social boom people
don't like living giving out their
social boom what's your date of birth
boom especially if it's a woman
you gotta ask her and look straight in
her eyes let him know that you're not
just [__] boom they once they give
you all that information now you got
them you got them guys then
before you went up to that at that store
he wanted a deposit
five on all deposit minimum a hundred
cash because that deposit strengthens
what we're [__] doing here and that's
where you're gonna sell that that I need
to bring that cash up to my manager my
manager is having a bad day his parents
were in Auschwitz you know his father's
got a tattoo on his forehead of Hitler
he's just having a [__] bad day you
know it makes him a Jew happy a nickel
cash and they're like really don't give
me that deal they'll give you whatever
you want
he wanted that [__] sticker you
wanted that invoice yeah give me the 500
I'm gonna get you the stick though I'll
go up to already [__] come back
already said I can't do it but the check
stayed up there
the check stayed up there
that's all that's all control
those things that they do to you are all
control guys
when I take you on the demo drive you
know I remember at BuildCraft Subaru
people were lazy Mike would come on I go
Mike what do you want to drive a GL 10
here put a plate on it take it for a
drive
wrong you're supposed to go with them
remember you drive off the lot that's
control you take them somewhere you
switch seats and then you tell them
again get out of your [__] car now
you make them fall in love with the car
they're driving around right oh my God
this car is so great guess what
on their drive at the light they saw a
[__] neighbor oh you selling this car
you know why because who wants to go
home and tell the [__] neighbor you
didn't buy the car because you're a
[__] credit Bandit because you're a
cheapskate you know what I'm saying so
you're driving you see a neighbor I
always tell people let's go buy a house
show it to your wife they don't even
know what the [__] you're doing that's
all psychological warfare they're gonna
go home short to the wife she's going to
fall in love with it she's going to
smell the [__] car oh my God I love
this my car smells like feet and ass you
know this car smells like new car smell
oh my God they go [__] nuts okay now
you showed the neighbors and you showed
your wife let's go home and [__] buy
it when I walk in there that's the first
thing I tell my salesman guess what the
wife saw it and the [__] African name
African-American neighbor saw it which
means he's going to want to outdo the
African-American he's not going to go
home without this car
he's not going on without this car let's
[__] with him a little bit it's got a
nickel deposit and let's see what we got
let's get let's start him at a 1600
profit
and we'll get him down for like a
thousand you get 30 of that you make 300
bucks if there's a CIF what's a CIF Joey
I'm the type of [__] you got to
give me cash to sell
Monday Tuesday and Wednesdays I wouldn't
sell you a car even if you were [__]
begging me to buy the car because
there's no bonus involved
there's no car bonuses involved so I
would line you up for Thursday come
Thursday why Thursday Thursday I'm gonna
say I'm gonna get you an extra Rim so at
the time at the at the bill Crouch place
I was a thief over there because if you
would buy a car I'd take him to the side
and go listen for an extra hundred I'll
say uh to call later let's say you got a
GL Subaru gl10 was the high end in the
in the late 80s I had a kid the lot man
stole the stereos out of the gl10 and he
would put them into the lower end ones
so a tremendous and one day the bank
came no high-end cars had high-end
stereos they all had AM FM just am
radios the bank was like what the [__]
is going on here where's the [__]
stereos
so that's all these things guys there
are so many psychological things like
when I was like when I was doing comedy
in the beginning when people were
calling all these comedy club Owners to
get work
I will call comedy club Owners to say
hello
they would go are you looking for a
week's worth and I don't know I just
want to call you say hello last time I
was Dad a good time my friend was there
last week he had a good time I'll talk
to you soon bye and I'd hang up on them
and they go what the [__] everybody
calls me for a week of work Joey is the
only guy that calls to say hello
that's the twist guys
it's not about selling your belly to
belly it's about the [__]
psychological like I said to you when
you come in to see me I am what's your
name Mike okay Mike what do you want to
do well me and my wife are really
looking but as I'm talking to him I
realize he's from North Bergen he's just
a little older than me I knew his
brother I knew his father
so I push him once
can I sell you a card for that
no okay what I'm gonna do is this I'll
push him again on the way out are you
sure there's nothing we could do today
nah Joey you know what man I know you're
here and when I'm ready I'll come see
you we want to go look at a Dodge Neon
you know whatever okay I give you a
brochure
and I write your information now if I
sent you back I get you do me a favor
let me get some information so I keep in
touch you let you know about sales or
what everything is happening some people
are very nice they give you your [__]
they give you their address their phone
number their work number they give you a
card to their work that means you got
them that means they're very serious
then I I play a different game with
these people you ready as soon as they
[__] leave
as soon as they're in their car and
they're pulling away
bye thank you for the uh yeah I run
right in and write them a letter
handwritten letter not printed off a
[__] computer in 87 there were no
computers to type on so I had to hand
write it but I would buy my own [__]
uh paperwork like printed like Joey Diaz
Bill crowd Subaru when you were pulling
off that lot I was already hey Mike I
want to thank you and your wife for
coming in to look at the gl10 uh sorry
we didn't have the color you had but
it's coming in about three days and I'll
keep in touch it's not coming in three
days
some book before he [__] gets home I
already licked that letter and it's on
their way in about two days or a day
they get the [__] letter guess what
else they get that night at about 6 30
quarter to seven a call from Uncle Joey
asking them if they got all the
information they needed there's anything
else I could do for them only thing I
could send them to make their car buying
decision they would go oh my God Joey
I'm so happy that you call now again in
three days I've already sent the letter
maybe a postcard of the car you ever go
to dealership and they have a postcard
with the car I would send them one of
those and then the third day I would get
a call people make a buying decision
between 72 hours so I would have 72
hours from the time you got in your car
to sell you that car if you were gonna
[__] Buy
so between the letter the postcard and
the call
I have to hope that and it's the same
thing with comedy guys
I gotta wish that people aren't doing
that
so if she talked to 3000 and they got a
letter a postcard and a call from me
checking in with them not telling them
there's a sale but checking in with them
to make sure I gave them all the
information they came in for you think
about that
you know what maybe the other three set
maybe the other two salesmen gave them
that information and also treated them
like that now the people got a harder
decision to make but if those other two
networks didn't do that and I was
dealing it with that did that what does
that tell you
if I'm saying to you when I used to go
for auditions what's the first thing I
did when I got home before I even put
the audition email and the old saved
[__] thing I would write out a card I
still got thank you cards in my desk I
would write out a [__] see now today
you send [__] audition tape who gives
a [__] they don't even you know they
don't know nothing but back in the day I
sent them a thank you card a a uh
Christine thank you very much for seeing
me today
it was really great thank you you know
what man again they probably saw 10
people how many people send a thank you
card as soon as they walk in
as soon as I walk in the house so I know
for a fact if I had a 10 a.m audition
and I walk in the house at 11 30 the
mail didn't come yet I'm putting that
[__] card and that's why I tell you
to do it when you walk in the [__]
door because if you do it later you're
gonna forget do it right now have the
envelope sealed put a [__] stamp on
that mother if you happen to mail it
that same day and that cash director
gets it the next [__] day in Burbank
okay while she's trying to she's going
to take a look at your audition again
she's going to take a look at your tape
again maybe that'll convince her to take
a look again let me take another look at
this guy maybe he didn't read well the
first time he'll read better the second
time these are all the things
selling will follow you for the rest of
your [__] life
you think if if Mike look right now we
always talk about Mick Jagger Mick
Jagger
it's the plane tickets for the band
if you I don't know if you guys know
anything about bands you think Guns and
Roses booked their own plane tickets
I don't think so you think [__] uh
the Red Hot Chili Peppers book their own
plane tickets I don't think so Mick
Jagger went to a business school
and he quit he never got his full
[__] thing but whatever he learned in
his business school he brought it into
his musical career you know Mick Jagger
when I got one I remember and whatever
it was
88 something like that I don't [__]
know the stones were playing Boulder
there was support I was real close to
both the stadium
That was supposed to start at 7 7 30.
I couldn't hear him I remember I said
[__] him maybe they canceled the show
and the next day I asked somebody how
come I didn't hear the stones go on
early and they go bro the stone didn't
go on until 9 [__] 30. and I go why
not and then a couple days late I found
out Mick Jagger called the tickets
weren't sold out no he was mad because
the tickets behind him
woman sold out
like whenever you see a band there's
always a stage and they leave behind the
stage open they fill in the sides it's
not a good seat Mick Jagger refused to
go up till they sell the stage behind
them the tickets in this behind them
that's a businessman that's a
businessman and his excuse was they got
to pay they see me shake my ass
okay that's a businessman guys
so what he learned at that business
school he took it Mick Jagger makes his
own plane reservations for the band
Mick Jag is very frugal not cheap
very frugal he's a business major
you know
I know for a fact if you have a band
there's not a lot of sharp guys and not
going to be five sharp guys one guy is
gonna run the whole thing with it with
Motley Crue it's Nikki Sixx it's what it
goes with [__] Guns and Roses they're
a band but it's actual [__] Rose
whatever the [__] Axel says is what they
do you know so every band has their
leader you know it was funny what I
learned from like Duff McKagan
Duff was saying that when he first moved
to LA he lived in the same building next
to slying the Family Stone you know Sly
Stone whatever his [__] name is and
that slide was living in a little
apartment smoking crack
that you know anybody who knows anything
about Sly Stone knows that
these [__] made 20 hits
how can he live in a [__] studio
apartment next to Duff you know years
later Duff ended up getting all this
education and economics degree and all
this stuff because he wanted to
understand where the money was in his
contracts he didn't want to end up like
one of those broke musicians Ozzy
Osbourne those guys in the 70s all got
[__] rough did you guys read the
article the other day about uh Steve
Harvey paying 400 000 a month to the IRS
400 000 a month 500 000 a month for
[__] taxes back taxes because it's
accountants [__] didn't uh file all
those years and they took his [__]
money this is the difference between a
musician that or comedian that doesn't
know what's going on
and a guy like Mick Jagger that he took
what he learned early on and brought
into his music bring it into your comedy
I was really happy because
yeah when I got to La I was using like
if I went for an audition I would write
you something if I wanted to audition
for you I would send you a package I
used
the lettuce system a lot I wasn't a big
email guy I wrote letters because that
that's what was big you know
um there was so many parts of salesmen
that helped me in my career later on
when I first got to L.A I met people
like uh
I forgot what the kid's name was he was
on tour with Dane Cook and
a bunch of those guys he was the house
and see he was he also ran
one of the clubs in L.A the club that uh
whether I got caught snorting coke off
the girl's monkey and they threw me out
they banned me I forget what the kid's
name is anyway
I mean listen like he's a great kid
but a horrible [__] comic
you know a horrible comic and I don't
mean to say this about anybody but it's
the truth and I think he even knows that
this point in his career he's not he has
done comedy in like 15 years this kid no
he hasn't he's still a promoter and he's
still like he'll host his room sweet kid
I like him I wish him all luck in the
world but he was never a funny guy
but I'll tell you what
any room this guy had
he would back in 400 300 200 I didn't
know what he was doing he used to
aggravate me I'd see this kid out and I
[__] throw malukia sticks at him with
my eyes you [__] I hope you
burned down I just didn't know what he
was doing but I couldn't be mad at this
kid either
you couldn't be mad at him you know why
he was selling as a comic he was selling
I I still remember when I got into
comedy with these comics that you would
travel with them on Fridays in Colorado
and on Fridays they would check into the
hotel room and they would go to the mall
to give away tickets to the show and to
talk to girls and to talk to families to
give away tickets guess how many times I
did that [__]
zelch never I don't ever want to say to
somebody hey you want to come see me do
comedy that's got to be the most
horrible [__] feeling in the world
later on you know like in 2010-11 people
come up and go can we watch you do
comedy yeah sure that's a different
story but me going up there going hey
excuse me what are you doing tonight
what are you and your wife doing tonight
what who are you yeah I'm a comedian my
name is Joey Diaz you might not know me
but you're going to in 10 years do you
want to come to a comedy show tonight
and you're like what the [__] are you
talking so I could never do that [__] I
always like them treat people how I like
to be treated if somebody comes up to me
trying to sell me like I mean listen
there's a time and a place for
everything I admire salesmanship I love
everything about it I am a fan I am in
touch with my realtor with Trish
Florentine
I bought this house from Trish and I
[__] love her and I was at lunch with
a couple of weeks when I'm like Trish
your customer service is
[__] invaluable she just looked at me
like I go we weren't in the house one
day and you were already inviting us to
your home for a party you know when we
got here there was [__] sheep what
stuff for the front of the house that
said congratulations there was balloons
there was candies you know she called my
wife all the time I mean my realtors
[__] customer service rating is a
hundred [__] plus I will do business
with her for the rest of my life and I
will refer because she got me into a
nice house and she never lied to me and
customer service across the board I give
her a hundred percent a salesmanship she
took care of me her honesty but again it
was the customer service
that [__] you know and that's even
with the web page with t-shirts I've
always tried to get back to you guys
like I just don't send you a patch and I
don't give a [__] about you when you
order a shirt for me all those days what
did you get with the shirt didn't you
get a letter saying thank you for your
[__] order
I took I did oh I took all that [__]
from a salesmanship
I took it off from salesman and [__] and
applied it to my [__] career so if
you don't know what the [__] is going on
with your career and you don't know what
the [__] going on with you
try sales try sales read a book on sales
you know what that [__] job
you know because you still got a cold
call people not really cold call people
but you still got to call people and go
hey Mike how you doing Joe Diaz You Came
the other day look at the Subaru
have you happened to pick anything up
and then they'll say I pick something up
go [__] yourself and I'll tell you what
there was a book I got
I will never forget this book and the
author of that book I will suck his dick
or I will sniff her [__] for free
because it taught me so much for free
for free because they put so much money
in my pocket with what they wrote in
that book and it was called
telemarketing in the 80s
now it's probably been called 20 it's
telemarketing in the 2020s and basically
it broke everything you had to do to for
phone work now I read this book when I
was selling Chryslers when I went back
to South Subarus or something like this
this book was the one I reread
when I got into the sports betting
system
because whether it was a sports betting
system I worked for whether it was
selling cigars on the phone whether it
was selling cars it always came back to
sales
and once
you see it
it took me a while but once you see it
you'll see that everything in your life
revolves around sales
in its own special way you have to
do something to get them to keep
so what you're doing is selling
number one rulers always be [__]
honest tell them the truth tell them
what you can do and what you can't do
and that's listen guys I was a liar I
was a cheat I was a [__] burglar I
was a lot of piece of [__] things but
when I sold cars I was straight up a
hundred percent gangster you know I had
outgrown all that you know it's so weird
how it was a cop I was a [__] piece
of [__] in my regular life but when it
came to sales
comedy especially comedy
I did them a hundred percent
to the [__] T I never stole jokes I
never [__] called other Bookers and
try to throw comics on them you know
there's no for me sometimes I'm like I
can't believe that I was selling out
theaters and all this [__] for me
I still can't believe how well I did but
at the same time I could believe it
because nothing happened to me until I
Incorporated the salesmanship part of it
and that was through my space and you
know you're putting your shows up your
available shows and people are coming
and then you just learn like even with
Twitter I knew how to work Twitter at
the end if I had a show on Friday put it
up on Sunday night people usually that's
why people get pissed at me all the time
some some people just left patreon
because they're like hey man you don't
do anything on Saturdays and Sundays
[__] you [__] you if you're on the
computer on Saturday and Sunday shoot
yourself just shoot yourself you should
be going on a computer like maybe five
minutes to look at your messages or
something but to sit there in front of
Twitter and be posting on a Saturday and
Sunday I would never do that and if from
a sales perspective when you go on
Twitter post on Saturday see what
happens
nothing because all the people that are
going to spend they're out spending
they're out jumping up and down why are
you selling when there's nothing to
[__] sell Sunday morning go on
Twitter it's the same eight people on
there tweet look at me what what are you
[__] [__] there's nobody on that
Sunday night it's gonna be normal is
getting back on let's see what happened
in the world of social media this
weekend well I was out getting my dick
sucked VD and getting finger banged and
everybody else to sit on the computer
waiting for something to happen in their
life that's what they do they go on on
Sunday nights they start looking and go
holy [__] Joey's gonna be here Friday
night let me buy my tickets then the
only times I posted on a Sunday night I
wake up on Monday and I sold 200 tickets
overnight
because people want to lock up that week
they don't [__] look at the computer
during the weekend so I wouldn't post
her in a weekend but Monday through
Friday when I was out there [__]
knocking on doors I was posting every
day but if you look at my post I was
posting nice and light three four posts
in the daytime and that's it wasn't my
whole [__] day look at me I'm gonna
I'm gonna [__] plane look at me I'm
gonna [__] now because it was all
part of the salesmanship can you have
you ever been a Salesman have you ever
[__] been like right now
I need insurance so a couple weeks ago I
talked to an insurance guy I think he
sold my number to everybody every
[__] day insurance people call here
the ones I tell to go [__] themselves
are the ones that call 10 times in a day
I don't want to talk to those people
those people just obnoxious [__] suckers
the ones I talk to are the ones that are
very calculated you know what I'm saying
two two calls on one day three calls a
week later you know they calculated
these other people are [__] gavones
that's how I want to be treated I don't
mind you selling I don't mind you
selling I can't be really I'm a
hypocrite if I give you this
conversation then I'm mad at you for
sale all I can tell you is to control
your [__] you know if you bang me out
10 times in a day eventually you're
gonna piss me off I'm gonna tell you go
[__] yourself right or wrong that
anybody's gonna do that but if you call
with a purpose and sell
with a purpose
he'll be fine for me nothing happened I
was doing Brea was where I learned
salesmanship and comedy I got a call one
day I wasn't doing anything you know I
was opening up a Rogan
I really wasn't going to the store at
all
and I'll never forget this guy this guy
called me from The Improv I still talked
to him
Dan
the man I love this guy that he called
me one day and he was like bro I really
believe in you this is when nobody was
talking to me it was like Rogan Mitzi
Shaw and a couple Comics nobody [__]
ever said nothing to me this guy called
me he's like man I've been watching you
on stage I think something's gonna
happen with you I want you to do a dirty
show at the bray Improv
he goes fourth for three months I'm
gonna give you 400 a month
that's 150 the headliner
150 to 150 for the headliner
a hundred for the feature act and then
you keep 50 150 for booking or whatever
he goes I'm gonna do that for three
months and after that you start at zero
you don't have to learn how to build a
room
I was [__] petrified but I tried it
the first month the second month and I
did a little differently I got a bunch
of I got all my friends
Felipe [__] Martin you know Rick
Ramos Steve Simone I would get all of
them down there every month and break
them all a 50 bill
I would give them all [__] 50 bucks
so I would have the best show ever they
would all come down I would have Reef
for there I would have reefer people
come down and then the 30-day the 90 day
thing came and I'm like how am I gonna
get people in that
I was knocked I didn't go for Rogan
right away or call him to do a favor I
said no I gotta learn how to build this
room so I'm going to build it so I
started building it with my post
Rick dukerman once told me when you
invite people to your showcase another
reason why I don't know if you guys
watch the Ryan sickler showcase couple
weeks ago I was telling about my agency
the coloring book you know I had the
coloring book because I was too much of
a [__]
to call these agents and tell them what
I could do whenever I was talking to him
I would talk to them like yeah like you
know if you got something to say say it
don't [__] around with people because
that tends to be to your salesman
ability if you're not confident in your
[__] Spiel that's it they smell that
so I was never comfortable when I first
got into [__] comedy doing it but
once Dan told me I had to learn how to
build the room I go let's go back to my
salesmanship skills started taking
pictures posting my MySpace I started
[__] writing crazy posts on MySpace
that was when Lindsay Lohan was doing
blur every night and sucking [__] so
every time I would post a show I would
go this it was like once a month on a
Tuesday but I would always go this
Tuesday me Felipe Lindsay Lohan's doing
coke Three Chicks of that [__] and
sucking do you know any people come up
to me after the show and go was Lindsay
Lohan here
I didn't see you tonight I would go what
the [__] they actually believed that
and that's what Rick dukerman said to
always call the people the next day and
go where were you last night Mike I
couldn't make it oh you missed it Rodney
was here dice was here they [__] lit
my ball sack on fire you [__] up you
missed it you always want to let them
think like they [__] missed something
so the next day I would go on there and
write a little [__] speech last night
to Brea Improv we shot a cannonball of
some chick's ass and then I started
getting 10 people
20 people
30 people
started going to 100 people and by the
time I gave up the room
in 2012
the last 12 months we had sellouts in
that [__] room
from me adding
I use that room before I tried the
salesmanship on my career at that time
[__] Dane Cook had written the book
on following through with uh
you know on on at night Dane Cook would
go back home after my space and [__]
you know just thank people for coming
for the shows that interaction is
another form of sales the reason why
Facebook is so great is because people
could see the interaction you're having
with people and that opens them up you
know
that's my talk about [__] sales on a
beautiful Wednesday what I wanted to get
through to you guys was that
if you're a musician
if you're a conductor if you're a
violinist if you're anything in
Performing Arts
and you're trying to get people to come
get you and you're still putting flyers
on cars
that's not going to work anymore
I think for me the internet is the best
selling [__] tool there is
on the Earth today it's Press buttons
you know you still got to come through
you've still got to have The Gift of Gab
you still got to talk to people and talk
them all off the ledge after you ask
them for money and whatnot but it's
always the value that you're selling you
know I I never scam people on my posts I
always told people you know 56 and
slinging dick there was never a picture
of me with a hat smoking a cigarette
looking mysteriously trying to sell you
on that I'm selling you on the fun night
you're gonna have
I'm selling you on after this [__]
show how much fun you're gonna have from
the energy of all that laughter that's
what I'm selling you on so if you want
to be a great artist in today's world
I'm sorry I know that you have [__]
listen as artists were half [__] we
want to be good at one thing some of us
do all some of us do have to get the Gap
but if you're an artist and you don't
have the gift to get what do you do you
know I know a couple comments that don't
have the gift the Gap have somebody help
you
have somebody help you learn
you know uh
[__] I wish I had a sales book to
recommend for you guys it wasn't one
book in particular it was ten books and
then going to Anthony Robbins seminars I
know you're looking at me going Joey you
went to Anthony Robbins seminars I tell
you what
I'm not an Anthony Robbins live and die
type of guy but I will tell you he's got
a couple things that [__] uh do help
to help me and to be honest here I still
[__] use them today and it's like
little things you could do to remember
so you could perform at a great level
all the time I did it for stand up for
years I'm not going to tell you what the
secret was pay Anthony Robbins 300 and
take a seminar and go walk on [__]
coals and then I'll [__] tell you I
love you [__] with all my heart
I thought this was important on a
Wednesday [__] morning to talk
to you people about sales in your life
we're all starting from scratch again
after this [__] pandemic a lot of us
are if you're struggling or something
like that add sales in there sales is
usually the key you can't listen I love
these people who are going to hire
marketing firms nobody could sell you
like you
nobody nobody can sell you like you how
did I find out remember all those years
I told you I would call agents
and say get me in for that and they'd
say well they don't really want to see
you until Joey wrote them a [__] note
or Joey picked up the phone because
nobody could sell you like you
that's it [__] suck is have a great
[__] week thank you for watching The
Joint and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors Jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you very much for supporting and taking
my Wednesday morning ear beating here we
go the joint is brought to you by
You by looking to see the devil there's
no better pipe on the [__] Market
than the freeze pipe you get a cold
[__] hit every time here's how it
works the pipe comes with a detachable
chamber you freeze beforehand right when
you're ready to see the devil you're
going to freezer you take it out you
attach it let me tell you something you
that smoke will be so cold you think
it's [__] inhaling from a penguin's
[__] it is tremendous there are weeds
that I [__] smoke that I don't even
feel the smoke going down my throat
that's how smooth it is smoking with the
freeze pipe it's like living in Aspen
Colorado you go outside you scoop up
from Sand uh snow you throw it in the
[__] bong and you [__] go bananas
you understand me it's non-toxic it
freezes faster than water and it stays
Frozen longer it's like a big dick on
Viagra freeze pipe cools down the Smoke
by hundreds of degrees but listen do me
a favor go to thefreeze pipe.com right
now thefreeze pipe.com pressing code
Joey j-o-e-y and save ten percent on
your first order you can get a bong a
pipe or a bubbler my favorite is the
[__] bubbler tremendous now again
that's the freeze pipe.com
pressing code Joey j-o-e-y to get ten
percent if you could smoke from it
freeze pipe [__] makes it listen
the joint is also brought to you by c b
d lion when I talk about CBD there's
only one [__] company I deal with and
that CBD lion why they give you a sheet
of third-party lab results when you go
to their web page to see how CBD can
help you and how the lion has your back
whether it's the kinesiology tape the
tincture the vapor pen the capsule I
mean listen the the the [__] CBD line
gummies or melatonin you sleep like a
[__] baby ballet enough is enough go
to CBD line right now read the third
party lab results and at this something
you like I'm Gonna Get You 20 off when
you use code Joey or joint at
cbdlion.com I want to thank CBD lion I
want to thank freeze pipe I want to
thank [__] on it I want to thank
manscape and I also want to thank Bank
liquid IV a tremendous [__] company
I'll see you guys next week tip top
Magoo stay black Uncle Joey loves you
[Music]